back in Indianapolis Scouting Combine
our next guest has been a cornerstone of
the Steel's organization for 21 years he
is general manager Kevin Kohlberg Kevin
welcome back how are you thanks guys is
always fun to be here and get started
with the combat here we go baby
and congratulations contract keeping you
around your on a year-to-year plan now
but you made it clear you got no intent
to go anywhere I also know a lot of
people would like to say well the
Carolina Panthers fans hey let's get
Kevin Kolbert you're staying with the
Steelers indefinitely yeah I mean I've
never had any other thoughts quite
honestly it's really just a personal
preference that you know mr. Rooney art
was a very agreeable - which was great
and you know quite honestly I mean you
know being out of the playoffs two years
in a row we have something to prove that
we can get back to it and that's that's
what we're gonna take this year for but
personally it was a preference
professionally that's where we are and
that's fortunately we're able to do it
so we just have to deliver on 2020 the
Mike Tomlin just right off the bat would
you say it was one of the best years
you've seen him coach since he's been in
the Pittsburgh Steelers there's no
question you know Coach never said oh no
you know was always let's go and that's
the way he operates
coach Ben's done for the year all right
what's what's next coach we lost the
font to it okay let's go and he really
relayed that to his team his team
responded we weren't good enough we know
that eight and eight I mean as good as
it was it wasn't good enough to get
there and that drives all of us crazy
quite honestly but coach coach did a
remarkable job of making us competitive
but he'll be the first to tell you he's
not satisfied the Ben Roethlisberger
situation I saw that you said earlier
today at your press conference you
expect them to be even better this year
what makes you think that as he gets
closer and closer to 40 and coming off
of that elbow surgery what makes you
think he actually will be improved and
what he's been in the pen again you know
and you know this Chris you sit out a
season your body you know physically you
gotta you got a little bit of a break
lose some things timing wise rust and
all that sure that'll be a factor but
physically he didn't have a way
tear of one year on his body the surgery
you know when you when you have any type
of injury it's hard to say you know when
that injury occurred but you don't know
what was what you was leading up to that
was a ligament was a muscle was a bone
weak who knows but you know we're
optimistic that coming off a surgery his
arm will be better his body will be
better we know his competitive spirit
will be better because he wouldn't do
this if it wasn't that's why I'm
encouraged that he could even be better
now okay now behind that okay yeah Mason
Rudolph had some good and some bad and
duck same thing it was some good and
some bad you're gonna stand pat there
behind Big Ben or do you think you might
have a you might have to bolster that
position for the just in case Ben gets
hurt again
I mean coming out of the preseason Mason
earned at number two spot you know he
outplayed Joshua and we were able to
trade Josh of course when we trade him
and Ben gets hurt Josh is an NFL
quarterback right but Mason proved in a
preseason and we thought he was our best
option as number two as a second year
player first year starter he was five
and three yeah and most backup
quarterbacks if you can get a five and
three record a ten and six or a ten and
six projected over 16 you'd be happy
with yeah you're right who's to say he
would have been five and three had he
played more games here no your most
encouraging thing about Mason was he
started off okay
he hit a rough stretch coach made the
different made the changes as everybody
knew he would and and had to do Grayson
didn't like it he was disappointed but
he was challenged and the best thing was
when he got back on the field against
the Jets he probably played the best
that we had seen him play so he took
that challenge and was and accepted it
was better so moving in you know we wish
he could have finished that game he got
hurt but no we're encouraged by that
Devlin Hodges did a representable job he
was three and three yeah and we're not
going to discount a guy like Paxton
Lynch you know Paxton has the physical
abilities of a first-round player we
picked him up you know during the season
could he get in up to speed now it
wasn't
that time yeah with a full offseason we
throw him into the mix we're gonna feel
good about that position right
the miles Garrett Mason Rudolph incident
got a second life a couple of weeks ago
after miles Garrett was reinstated he
said what he had to say
Mason Rudolph's lawyer has suggested
there could be litigation against
Garrett for defamation based upon the
allegation Mason used a racial slur does
the organization have a preference as to
whether or not Mason just lets it go and
we all move forward or does the
organization think if he believes his
rights were violated he should take
Miles Garrett to court and fight it out
there yeah we thought coach did a great
job when he addressed both both
questions in his last interview about
the situation and the most significant
thing he said during that interview was
we all need to move forward and we will
as a Steelers move on from this and we
have and that's that's where it ends it
was addressed by coach and we've all
moved on all right I want to hit on some
free agency stuff you got some decisions
to make but before we get there I got to
ask you this cuz it just popped into my
head
Le'Veon Bell told everybody during the
season that he talked about lately I'm
about you know that oh yeah okay
tampering insurance I can give you a
generic real real end okay that at a
trade deadline my job is to provide the
organization with this is who is
available so anytime and I do that
that's my job I have to know these
players are available so we're gonna
check every player that we think is
available and that's that's that's
really yeah the situations and how those
things grow who knows I'll guess my job
to provide that yeah okay good good
answer there I got we can read between
the lines of what that was there but you
got a guy like bug Dupree how do you
balance this out in free agency this
year I mean because he had a year where
you'd say he's one of the you know in
the upper echelon some edge defenders
now he had some years before that where
I'd go I don't think he reached his
potential you know how do you balance it
out with that type of player was it a
money year but you know what is it every
time you know a player gets near free
agency and they put together that year
like I was a contract year right could
it be sure yeah but we thought bud was
ascending you know coaching had flipped
in he and TJ we saw more better results
out of him in 2018 we were encouraged by
that him and TJ together is really a
dynamic duo yes and if we want to keep
that together and we're very encouraged
look bud bud met the challenge he had a
great year yeah and the one constant you
know with everything that can go on is
we want bud to finish his career right
with the Steelers hopefully we're gonna
be able to get that done yeah you know
we had you dismissed Schuester at the
Super Bowl and we asked him about
Antonio Brown and how the things we've
seen publicly over the last year mesh
with what he experienced privately with
Antonio Brown have how big of a
disconnect have you seen between the guy
you knew behind the scenes in Pittsburgh
versus everything that's played out over
the past year you know and and in coach
addressed this as well in that same
interview and it will never change and
Tony O'Brien will always be a Pittsburgh
Steeler in our in our minds from it from
that personal standpoint we'll always be
there to support him when he needs help
if he needs help and that'll never
change
but as Antonio Brown 8480 the football
player know we've moved on from that and
we're comfortable with that but that his
our support of him as a person moving
forward that'll never change it never
changes really for any of our any of our
players that move on from us but when
you see and hear what's going on this
past year does it give you a level of
concern like something's not right here
he needs our help
we wish he would reach out if he saw
this a lot maybe we don't even right now
yeah you know what when we had Antonio
Antonio was the best worker in our in
our on our practice field
the most competitive guy on the game
field it was never any question about
that and we knew an Tonio Brown the
person as well and we tried to help him
grow as a professional football player
and he did during his time with us what
happened after that
I really can't address because I don't
know all the day-in and day-out issues
but we know and he knows that we he will
always be one of us and we're always
going to be there to support him
well Kevin we appreciate some of your
time congratulations on 21 years in
County with the Pittsburgh Steelers
and you guys almost got there last year
with a roster that was held together by
duct tape and glue and this year with a
healthier crew we expect to see you guys
playing in January I'm sure you do as
well so they hose thank you my year
thanks Chris thank you thank you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports